[Music]
welcome to
ear biscuits the podcast we're two
lifelong friends talk about life for a
long time
i'm linked and i'm red this week at the
round table of dim
lighting we're going to be talking about
our preparations
for some upcoming trips now that may
sound like
why are we going to talk about
preparations well
these just wait because these are
special trips these trips are special
well i mean we should say you're going
on a solo trip
yeah and i'm going on a trip that
i've visualized a lot in my mind and i
that may be a problem
but you're not going solo but not to
make me look bad we'll talk
right well we'll talk about that
yeah a little bit let's we'll talk about
the fact that i've planned my entire
trip to make you look bad
really that's a decided district well
but i chose to go on this trip first at
this time and then you were like well
you know we usually travel at the same
time but you were like well i'm going to
take my wife and i was like you're
trying to make me look bad
and by my wife i mean your wife you're
not taking my wife well have you talked
to her lately
i mean we're leaving like tomorrow's the
big prep day
and then so um
48 hours from right now we will both
be on the road there's
hopefully but there's a lot of question
marks associated with that
enough to talk about for an entire
podcast another question mark
uh is where'd you get that shirt you're
wearing
hey this i know this was your shirt
no that is my shirt there's no was about
it gave me this so
i i i have given you some shirts that
were too small for me
that one fits me well i feel like this
shirt is a little too big for me yeah
but uh there's an orange one and this
one and they're the same and you
you said these don't work for me and i'm
like okay well i'll take
these they're not the same so not a
sponsor that's an
elwood shirt which uh i like and i wear
and i got a big neck it's got a bigger
neck but it also it's a little bit
longer fit
it's a little longer and uh those work
and they haven't shrunk the orange one
was like a six dollar one like a blank
that i got off of uh
amazon what i'll tend to do is i'll buy
blank
shirts that are the same kind of shirts
that we uh print on
here at mythical i don't even know what
brand it is
next level or something like that i'll
find blanks because i like to wear plain
t-shirts
but sometimes the you know and not
everything's they're not always the same
size depends on the color
and and that orange one got a little bit
too small there was there was another
one with the orange one it was this one
that was i wasn't i did i didn't mean to
give you that shirt can i give it back
what's in it for me yeah that doesn't
have
you have another shirt you can keep the
orange i don't
i don't like orange on me well that's i
i gave it to you because it didn't fit
me will you change the color of the
orange shirt
i'll dye it for you yeah like tie dye it
bleach it
uh just stain it thoroughly to where it
looks like a different
hue and then i'll give you this i mean
do you want it right now you want me to
do this shirtless
nope i do not want that some people
might but i do not
um we also need to catch up well first
of all you we need a cat update because
ah you know the presentation there was
quite a build up there
um yeah because theoretically we could
have a kitten right now
but the plan was when we get
chris and i get back from our trip then
we will
get the cat because the the cat so
what's happening the kitten will be old
enough
we decided that we're gonna get this
kitten
and um of course you know in the
presentation it was yeti
the the the white cat and then that cat
turns out that cat was adopted that's
what happens usually
and then she was like well i'll just
take the black cat
which she's calling opal but then i and
it may have been right after we recorded
i went home or a few days later and
there was this whole kerfuffle the
that cat was adopted out from underneath
her teeth you gotta act fast with cats
well we were they were uh lily and chris
were upset because they did the
paperwork
the adoption paperwork like the
application that said
this is the cat that we want you know we
we've been in contact with the cat just
to kind of clarify the whole thing
and the application was approved
and then the next day is when they found
out that the cat oh
somebody else came in and adopted
another cat but then because
they were willing to adopt two cats they
were giving
given preference and they were given
your cat
of course she didn't say your cat and
that just doesn't seem
right to me it didn't seem right to any
of us but
ultimately after the person at the
adoption agency ended up saying listen
you know what
this is my fault you i
it seems like if she had to do it again
she would have given
lily the cat but she was not gonna
take the cat back from the people who
adopted two cat kittens
so the long and short of it is
we did not secure this cat it the cat
has been
unsecured it has been adopted by another
family just get another black along with
a sibling just get another cat
i was like there's already settled for
the second cast yeah that's what that's
what i told them for the third
either that or let's just not get a cat
so what i mean
so are you saying that when you get back
from your trip you're gonna go and
you're gonna
pick the cat a new cat lily was so mad
well i understand that that
there's been no other plans made i think
the
assumption is that there's some cooling
off period where it's like whenever we
talk about it
she's just so hot under the collar about
it
that we can't get to well let's actually
look for another cat and i'm not pushing
the issue maybe this is part of this
they wanted a cat
maybe this is part of the system maybe
they do this with everyone
it's a test let's tell them we gave
their cat away and see if they're a
reasonable person well you got to think
about that i think about everything
lily let them have it and then she
talked to them directly yeah christie
lily got on the phone with the good for
her you know what that's what listen
i was really proud that's what these
kids should be doing you know
i know i sound like an old man a lot
well i am i'm 42 i mean 43
probably probably 43 about you know a
couple weeks after this comes out
listen you young folks
you can't handle life's issues either
via text or via your parents
he's got to get on that phone do
something i was surprised i was um
take control of your own issues i was
very proud of her for get for getting on
the phone
it didn't help the moral of the story is
uh
yeah you should have said that you
should have said it worked convinced her
well it didn't work i mean
so now it's just it's been it's been
like a week
of not really talking about it cooling
off
cat cooling off period so we'll see
we'll see what happens
um okay i'm waiting anxiously now
uh another thing that we have to update
you on
uh again i don't know exactly lots i
don't know exactly when this is coming
out but i do know
that um it will have been a few weeks
uh since this happened but i uh well no
you tweeted
you tweeted something oh oh okay the
boot tweet
yeah well okay yeah i tweeted
this was saturday night after i did
like my listening party with britain
and let's see where is this where's the
text scroll scroll scroll
well it'll probably be under your
twitter it's another way to do it
but you're yeah and 9 30 at night well
what i
what i tweeted out was just got a text
from
rhett that said come to living room to
discuss
boots that's it no period
no follow-up no nothing and i'm just
staring at that
no don't don't do please don't share the
follow-up text yet
okay we'll get we'll get to that well so
that's what i tweet i tweeted that
and then uh well no well you also
tweeted back at me
you you texted back to me you're like
can i tweet this and i was like
sure tweet it yeah yeah you tweeted it i
responded to you
the mythical beasts who are you know
tuned in
to our twitter conversations that's a
certain set
you guys were very uh concerned uh there
was a lot of conjecture
about what may have been meant whether
or not i was in link's house
where we going to discuss boot so right
now we're about to clear up the
discussing boot
controversy and let me tell you every
single
possible idea that you have about it is
more interesting than the actual
explanation and that's why
i've let it sit for a while i have not
heard the actual explanation
except except the follow-up text except
the follow-up text
but i mean my follow-up tweet when you
did not tweet anything back
my original tweet just got a text from
rhett mc that said come to the living
room to discuss
boot and then you know people are like
seems very urgent
just go meet just go meet up with him
he's waiting for you
you sure it's rest right this time
and then i wrote back i tweet i tweeted
replied to myself just to give an update
and i was like
we are not in the same house i'm scared
which just seemed to like send people
into a
a tizzy but i mean that the text that
you sent back to me privately
yeah after come to living room to
discuss boot right was
whoops sorry
that was meant for lock and then i said
can't imagine how that text would not be
strange for anyone to receive
right so it was a
you sent it to me you meant to send it a
lot i still have no clue
what you want to discuss boot well let
me come to the living room to discuss it
let me tell you that
the link lock uh mix up has happened
before i
i can't this is definitely the funniest
example of it
but i go to my phone to text someone
my son in this case yeah and i just see
you know it's like
i think i i'm about to to you know
press lock but i press link and then you
know next thing you know i've sent a
text anyway
so the i'm gonna make this short because
it's uninteresting
lock sprained his ankle on like thursday
okay and he's like me
he's a hypochondriac and he has
catastrophized
uh how bad the ankle sprain is and what
it's gonna mean and all this stuff
he's had some issues with his ankles
high arches and um
so he's like talking about dad you got
to get me one of those boots
you got to get me one of those
immobilizing boots we got to go
tomorrow and get it and i was like look
there's we just can't there's no place
if you can pick this up i can order you
one like on amazon it'll get here monday
well i needed to discuss that with him
because he was like
figure out where we're going to go i bet
you were in the living room and i was in
the living room
and he was somewhere else and i texted
him come to living room to discuss boots
so you don't yell through the house you
just text as a form of intercom
you know we have google home so we will
sometimes broadcast
you can do that uh but
he was
i had some reason to believe that he was
not next to a speaker i can't remember
i thought you know i've never used that
feature by the way
oh it's constantly happening you don't
use the dinner time feature if you say
hg because i'm not going to say it
because i don't want your google devices
to go up
consider it if you say hg it's dinner
time
she rings a bell come and get it ding
ding ding really and it rains everywhere
and all your good homes
i didn't know about that we use it in
fact this morning
i as i was leaving i heard jesse say hg
broadcast shepherd get up
now because it's because she doesn't
know where he could be anywhere in the
house of sleep
well you can actually broadcast directly
to a person's room now that's a new
feature like in the past
month you can say broadcast to
shepherd's room
get up now shepard so locke has a
sprained
ankle so you're making him come all the
way down
all the stairs on the spring ankle all
the there's other stairs
even into the living room no the living
room is outside farthest point
he was outside and also again i was
handling all this for him
he's a 16 year old kid let him let him
he should be able to he should
discuss boot in his own mind and buy
boot
because listen we bought boot yeah and
yesterday
boot arrived yeah and he put he tried to
put boot on
and i could tell he could not figure
boot out and he was like does it figure
out boots well it's a complex boot
it's just a bunch of velcro straps right
no but there's an infla there's a valve
and it inflates and there's
things that you stick in yeah it's very
inflatable 75
and so probably not all of them so i
said i knew this was going to happen
i was like i saw him up there fumbling
when i was i was like
you figuring it out he's like not really
i was like well i believe in you and i
just walked away
because you i'm just i don't want to
they got to do things on their own man
yeah because one of these days it's just
going to be you and boot
no help count as discuss boot like what
you just talked about
what did that does that count yeah i
believe in you
yeah no just that part was discuss boot
as well
anytime we talk about buddhist
discussing boot but people thought so
many different things like
oh lots of people were like is it book
are they writing another book discuss
book
i would text you a couple people said
i'm not gonna be showing up for that
appointment yeah so
it's it's much less interesting than you
all
thought uh it's just a and it's an
actual boot
but i did go into my living room you
weren't there yeah
you know which i tweeted i believe well
we just called everybody up on
everything
we're so caught up now we can move into
the future
and talk about our big plans
i have this sense that
we're going to talk about these plans
and then something's going to happen to
one of us and this is going to be
oh gosh i don't know it's just you i
have to say i have a sense of
impending doom and i i almost wish i
didn't say it and there's good reason
for that which we'll get into
yeah uh but first we want to remind you
about the vote like a beast campaign
vote like a beast.com
check it out just go to the site it
can't hurt yeah and
i you know another thing i love about
the internet is i love
all the conspiracy theories about vote
like a beast
you can't do anything today like you if
you li if you say listen
this is a non-partisan effort
to get the vote out no no no that's not
good enough
people like people are like no way it's
nonpartisan
comments is it in a particular place
like is this the only
facebook is a cesspool i don't go to
facebook but um
the uh i just saw it in like when i when
i first posted just the picture on
instagram which was
just vote like a beast and just said
something about you know
inform yourself about the candidates
whatever it was like oh man
it just first of all you've got the
partisan stuff happening on the post
which i get is the election
but the the the conspiracy theories
about
the color choices of this the fact that
the beast hand is red
and the other hands are blue and gosh
it's just like i
i love it and the text is white oh my
gosh it's red white and blue
yeah because we're in america uh
but anyway it was uh yeah next year
we'll do or next year four years from
now we'll do green and yellow
no we won't we'll do red white and blue
again what is green and yellow
i just it's not red and one i know that
but like what is that like brazil i
guess
this is for the elections in brazil
in the brazil in the brazilian am i
wrong about that there's a little bit of
blue
i think there's a blue circle of some
kind there's a symbol that's blue yeah
a little blue in it that's what we'll do
yeah
anyway uh i mean it could work for any
global election just so you know it is a
conspiracy we are backed by the
illuminati
uh and you go to votelikeabeast.com at
your own peril
um so there you go vote like we started
watch out you might
you might find the tools necessary to
vote to
to uh and to connect your actual beliefs
and passions
with the candidates that are on your
ballot you know watch out the best one
the best one was
a guy that said interesting they're
finally big enough where the government
is using them
and there was like 20 thumbs up so this
guy
and 20 other people are like yeah that's
like that is interesting the
government's using them
government's using us i love being used
by the government
it's you know and i'm glad you can have
a sense of humor about it that's why i
don't read the comments because
it just it perplexes me and it's it's
hard for me to uh
don't be perplexed man to see it in a in
a comedic light people believe all kinds
of stuff
okay vote like a beast.com
all right so as you said uh this is a
solo trip for me and this is something
that
i have been planning for i've been
intending
for a long time right so ever since i
started going to therapy a couple years
ago uh one of the things that my
therapist does on a regular basis
is take solo trips like you know he'll
go
take like a you know he can do like
twice a year he'll do like an over a
week long
trip well that's a sabbatical if you go
over a week
and uh sabbatical he's always talked
about and you know i've known
you know uh had some friends who
like they kind of got into a rhythm
where each year both the husband and the
wife would take like a week-long
solo trip and people have talked about
this being
he's been encouraging it for a really
long time both for me and for jesse and
jesse is
heading off on a solo trip like um a few
weeks from now
and again he's just like it's just a
different
it's a different vibe especially when
you are you've never done it before
and and you know each person has their
own reasons why they would
want to do it and what might be you know
the benefits of it
but he just talked about he's just like
you know you unplug and you you kind of
have an intention
and you just get out there and you don't
really know
exactly what's gonna happen but he's
just like
at this point i couldn't do without him
like they are like my reset button right
and you hear people talk about this like
you know
i don't know if it's an urban legend but
like rivers cuomo goes off
from month every year into a silent he
does like a silence silent retreat
so he doesn't speak for a month every
year there's places you can go
yeah like monasteries i think and do
like that would be an option
silent retreat a yoga retreat would also
be
especially out here in in california i
mean
it is a tenet of mythicality i mean in
the book of mythicality we devoted a
whole chapter to
isolate yourself with yourself and so on
this very podcast we talked about the
first solo trips that we each took
years ago so if you're interested in our
first solo trips you can
you can look that up i went to slab city
which is like
out in the out in the desert below
joshua tree and you went you went joshua
oh because we didn't go at the same time
i don't think so yeah yeah uh yeah you
went off
off into some like some blm land which
uh bureau of land management yes
you have to clarify that yeah i noticed
that the other day because i was looking
for some
blm information about you can camp
anywhere on black lives matter
like i was looking for some blm bureau
of land management information for
dispersed camping
and it's just like oh yeah yeah okay yes
the hashtag has been taking over you
have to spell it out now which is great
that's good that's good that's
really good um so
yeah and that trip was only uh two a
night or two it was i think it was
mine was three i didn't eighteen you
went longer than i did but i wasn't
alone
i went to slab city and interacted with
people a lot to clarify i'm not
necessarily going to be
out of human contact but okay but let me
just
i thought you were well no i am going to
be out of human contact for most of the
time but i'm
but i'm not like um i'm going to places
where there is likely to be other people
at times so it's not like i'm not going
to speak to people i'm not going off
into the wilderness
completely isolated in one area for like
six days
because i think i think that's what it
is i think it's five nights six days
but you could get you could certainly go
two days oh easily without seeing or
talking to anybody based on what i've
heard of your
yeah well that's that's kind of i mean
we'll get into like why that might be
the case well
so one of the things that my therapist
has talked about and this is
i mean this is not exclusive like you
know
knowledge that he has this is just
common knowledge i think at this point
but
most people who go off and spend time
alone are like
you don't really experience the benefit
like anybody i've ever heard talk about
like a meditation retreat
like you really don't experience much of
the benefit
unless you get past like day three right
a lot of times
right around day three some people say
day five which is like the
almost the total time that i'm gonna be
out there is when like something clicks
and you're like
you know we don't really start to go
crazy right if that's what some people
may be thinking right now it's like if i
i've never been alone that long
is that are we talking about a breaking
point or a breakthrough
point they might be one of the same um
but this trip for me represent
but that's something your therapist it
tells you is that hey
you it doesn't need to be a short trip
it needs to be as long as you can make
it
so you can uh get past that
turning point well and specifically and
this is for me but it
probably applies to a lot of people it
takes a couple of days i mean i notice
this when i travel on vacation just
with the family it takes a couple of
days for me to
finally adjust to the pace of a vacation
i think about so many things i
i am constantly i have a low
level of anxiety about like 28 different
things that are related to
us professionally right i was thinking
about this the other day that
you know you guys know a lot of the
things that we do you see a lot of the
things that we do
publicly that sort of the ongoing things
that we do but we don't talk about what
it's like to run a company and to grow a
company and to deal with all the issues
that come with that we don't talk about
all the other projects that we're trying
to get off the ground we don't there's a
whole lot of things that we don't talk
about just because we keep some things
to ourselves we talk about a lot
but like sometimes it hits me even when
i'm like sitting down trying to meditate
and the point of the meditation is to
just focus on my breath and not think
about anything else
yeah monkey brain right i have monkey
brain just like most everybody and i
can't
just stop thinking about a million
different things
so what i've been told by the people
who've
tried to unplug is that listen it takes
a few days just
for to grab all the knobs and turn them
off
you know you're just finding another
knob and turning it off
and for me the whole point of the trip
is
you know i've been on this quest to try
to connect
with myself more and i don't say i'm not
saying that in a
self-absorbed way i'm saying that in a i
tend to be very much in my head
don't spend a lot of time in my heart
don't spend a lot of time understanding
what
knowing what i'm feeling really getting
into my feelings and understand what
that means
just knowing myself right and every step
i've taken towards that
has been beneficial not only for me but
for all the people in my life who i love
right
and i've been doing you know one sort of
outward manifestation of what i'm trying
to do internally has been me growing my
beard and my hair out i've talked about
that on an episode of your biscuits
and i've been kind of intending to do
this solo trip for a really long time i
was thinking it was going to be 20 20.
uh of course covet happened and so
things a lot of people's plans got
turned upside down
but it finally got it on the books right
you know we said let's just
carve the time out and then we'll start
figuring out what we're going to do
so this was a couple months ago that we
were like okay this is when the time is
going to be
uh it was before before
covet hit i think uh maybe it wasn't it
wasn't for me
i am going north
from los angeles um
one of the things that my therapist has
done many times and is kind of into is
going throughout throughout the western
united states and going to hot springs
and i'm a huge hot springs guy i love
hot springs i love hot water
and i'm you know i i'm not i don't
believe a lot of woo
stuff so i'm not like i don't
necessarily think that there's some like
spiritual thing that's gonna happen to
me at these hot springs maybe i'm open
to it but that's not why i'm going
i just love hot springs and i love the
idea he sent me these pictures
of like places he's gone where like he
drives his four-wheel drive vehicle
through these mountains and comes
through this hot spring and then he's
got this hot spring to himself
i mean it it is really cool mesmerizing
think about it you look on a map
and you can see like i mean when we've
gone off-roading and like our first
experience with hot springs
was when we went on that overlanding
trip to death valley and then you get to
this one little oasis in the middle of
this valley that has
nothing but way down there in the bottom
of the valley
you see there's some palm trees i mean
just what you would think
of an oasis and
there's a hot spring there and there was
some naked people
right we talked about that on a gmm
episode yeah and we came back
and and those are more that's like on a
road that most cars can get to there
might be an rv like some of the ones
that he showed me
that i may or may not be able to get to
are more isolated than that yeah you'll
you'll just see on the map it's say hot
springs but it looks like it's in the
middle of nowhere and some of them don't
even
aren't even on the map so
okay so anyway i this is where i and i
don't want to get too into weeds on this
but
the thing that is very the the sort of
the
key struggle that i'm dealing with at
this point two days out from departure
is what i've been dealing with for the
past two months which is
the balance of being prep prepared
versus having unrealistic or even
specific
expectations right because for me the
whole exercise the whole point of the
trip
is to not want to accomplish anything
right
my life and my brain
is sort of completely centered around
accomplishing things right
and i can't vacation without thinking
that i need to learn how to
do like i need to learn how to surf or i
need to i have these things that i get
in my mind that i feel like i have to
accomplish in order to make it
worth it and when you go on the solo
trip there is this like well i've got to
really i've got to come back with some
wisdom
i've got to come back with something
but also i would have what if i can't
find these places or what if i get there
and there's people there
what if i get there and and the big huge
question mark that has suddenly sprung
up in these plans is the freaking
wildfires that are consuming our state
and i'm not driving i am driving
directly towards one of them
but it's one that's not as big as some
of the other ones
but if you look at satellite imagery of
the state of california
there's smoke everywhere i mean wherever
i go i'm going to be
covered in smoke to some degree and not
only that
but just last night because of this
latest fire
like there's a bunch of fires that just
happened having just started recording
this i mean there's been
uh multiple fires but there's a couple
more that just started like over the
weekend
and now the santa ana winds are coming
in they've closed
all the national all the all the
national forests so like
sequoia is closed um
inyo is closed and both sequoia and inyo
especially inyo are ones that i would
have been like camping in right that's
right yeah
and so i don't know what that means for
all the blm land
or so you've got the bureau of land
management which is like
usually like crappier land that wasn't
good enough to be designated as a
national park or a
forest but you can do dispersed camping
and i've
you know i've got this rooftop tent on
on the fj cruiser
basically if i can find a place to park
i can camp but there are
no fires allowed and not just no fires
no stoves
no gas stoves like so you can't even get
hot water
on you as of last night you cannot have
a gas stove fire anywhere in a
national forest in california but that i
don't know what does that mean about blm
i've got like my little bullet
uh water boiler that i'm just like to
make like
quick meals and stuff i won't do that on
u.s
you know in a forest but in a national
forest but i'm gonna do it on blm land
because i gotta eat
but i mean there's no fire risk in that
what you don't need to do
is you don't need to fire off one of
those gender reveal rockets
basically that's what this is all about
i'm gonna go into the desert and do a
gender reveal
of myself that's why i mean that's what
said
the fire south of us i started my
freaking gender reveal party i know
why what are they doing having a gender
reveal party and it was over 100 degrees
and they're outside firing off of a a
pink or blue smoke
that caught fire they tried to put it
out it it goes over the hill
and then they're evacuating thousands of
people and did you hear what
the they're saying they're going to
nightmare they're going to
uh make that family be responsible
to pay for the damage of the fire
what do you mean are they are they
billionaires because otherwise
no i mean they should obviously be held
accountable but like
i saw an article like family has to pay
i was like
out of what they're sorry that's all you
can i mean they learn
you know they've been made an example of
yeah so that's complicating things
because fires are i
i don't have a so sad i have a i've got
all these apps and all these maps
yeah downloaded right and i've got like
and like my family laughs at me because
every single
weekend i'm out there like putting stuff
into the truck and i've got like
these drawers in the back of the fj now
with all my stuff in it
i am so prepared and i'm really excited
about the rooftop tent
oh yeah but that's nice my route i plan
on using that
my route takes me up into um
like basically like heading up towards
mammoth and that whole like
valley all the way up on the 395 has got
there's hot springs and stuff
and then uh my options after that
depending on how i feel or
i could go all the way up to northern
nevada i could go all the way to idaho
if i if it hits me but i think i'm going
to get too far away at that point then
it would be too tough to come back but
there's wildfires
all along this route and so i just don't
know
every single night i'm going to have an
intention on the general area in which i
would like to sleep
and kind of bed down but
it's so up in the air there's i'm not
i'm not doing any formal campgrounds i
have a portable toilet
with a privacy pop-up thing okay i have
a
solar shower like i am going to be
completely self-sufficient i don't have
to stop anywhere except for gas
um so let me
let me share my plans a little bit and
because i and then i want to come back
to
like what is what is going to be your
practice
you know because because i'm i'm
interested in that but just
just to kind of skip over to to my thing
yeah once you carve out those dates
it's so much easier to say oh i'm gonna
i'm gonna do the same dates i'm gonna
plan my own trip
and i really like the idea of doing
another solo trip
and i definitely have this a feeling
that like i could really benefit from
that and i definitely want to do it
um but i've had this thing that
i've told you about the vans you know i
started this hashtag van life stuff i
did i've started following all these
people who live out of these
mercedes sprinter vans that have been
modded out with a bed and a kitchen
and some of them have a bathroom inside
and then you can have
four-wheel drive oh it just looks so
good on instagram
oh just look at those pictures of that
person just a van in the middle of
nowhere
and i'm like i can see
this in my future and i start talking to
you about how you can see it in your
future i'm gonna get one of these veins
you see it in christie's future
because it's in her future at this point
yes i'm like
really romanticizing this idea of not
selling my house and living in a van
but having this van it's basically the
cool hipster version of an rv
you know we had our rv trip to grand
canyon a few years back
and lando was excited to do it again but
and christy had a good time but the the
older kids it
that it just didn't resonate that much
with them and i'm like
well i can see in retirement me and
christie are gonna
like be that kind of people like once
lando
is like out of the house so like you
know you know he's 14. you're gonna send
him off early well like
let's just say eight years from now it's
like i could see that
we could do something like that me me
and christy could just have these like
van
excursions and sh and she can see this
as well
i'm starting i started to show her
pictures on instagram it's like in that
cool
look at where they are there's this how
does she respond specific
one that floats around and it's
a point of view shot of someone
getting up out of the bed in their
sprinter van
going over to the burner taking the hot
coffee
in a mug off opening the door to the
sprinter van
and then i've seen them jumping this
then walking out of the sprinter van
walking onto this little dock and then
jumping into this beautiful mountain
lake are you gonna be the coffee are you
gonna make those kinds of videos on your
trip and i'm like i'm showing this to
her
and i'm like we're gonna make these type
of videos like
in our retirement years and then i'm
like you know what screw retirement
i want to i want to know now if this is
even viable
so i bought one no you can rent you can
rent these
sprinter fans it's like just like
there's a there's a site called
outdoorsy which is like the airbnb from
your video
the one you're having a bathroom
the first one i was gonna rent didn't
have a bathroom but then i was like you
know what
this is so much about so much hinges on
us having a
good experience me and christy and again
it's just the two of us we're not taking
the kids
it's like if she hates this it doesn't
i see no way forward is this a bathroom
you can take a [ __ ] in um
so i'm like i'm renting one with the
bathroom so it's a toilet that yeah you
can crap
in there and the toilet is in the shower
so it's a toilet
in a shower oh [ __ ] in the shower
already so sad
it's just a simon that's a shower with a
with a
a grateless drain wow no you just you
put the lid down and you can sit on the
lid of the toilet or st
or like i don't know i guess hover where
does it go though where does the
feces go uh onto the highway
no i it goes into a container yeah and
then you take that container around with
you and it makes the whole van smell
no well i don't know maybe the
technology has gotten better you have to
test it there's a city i could test it
out
there's a seal you know the there's
definitely
there's a seal down there that eats it
that's why it costs so much because you
have to have an environment for a seal
that poor seal man that's what you
should feel bad about
that you got to seal this you and your
wife's crap all
the whole trip all right i mean you
thought zero was bad
and it's
when we did the rv it was like there was
no crap in in the rv toilet that was our
rule
just like when we were on and that was
based on our experience in 2008
being on an rv and somebody's saying
don't nobody no but we got crap in this
we're gonna crap in this thing and we're
gonna
figure it out we're gonna see that's
part of the test yeah um
otherwise these other sprinter vans that
don't want to dedicate the internal
space to like a
shower they'll have a shot a shower
hanging off the back
and then they have a portable toilet
like what you have and you just you'll
just do it in the middle of the van or
you'll do it
with a curtain around you what you're
talking about well mine's mine is a
um it is a it folds up to like a
briefcase
but then the legs come out of business
and then you sit on it and it there's a
bag that basically and i've got like 12
bags or something like a diaper genie
it's basically like a diaper kind of bag
and so
and like i was reading the reviews and
this one mom was like
our family of five used one bag for the
for the three day trip
and i'm like what but see i think what
it is is you take that bag
and you seal it up and then you put it
so i've got the trasharoo which is my
out
it's the trash on the outside of the of
the truck that's on the back
spare and then i think you just take
that bag and you put it out there so
it's outside and so it's not in your car
you can't do that in bear country but i
don't think you're going to bear country
you're going to
yeah well i would be going right i do
have
bear spray by the way i've got two cans
of bear spray
if i go to the west of 395 which is
where you're getting up closer to
sequoia and everything
yeah that's bear country if i were to go
hiking or whatever well you're not going
there anymore the problem is
that's where all the fires are so i'm
probably going to go on the east side
there might be bears out there
you you're saying the bears you're not
talking you're talking about
just the trash being on the outside yeah
yeah yeah yeah i'm i'm
if i'm in a place that i think that
there's bears then i'll put everything
inside
so you can boondock which is basically
you can camp in your you can car camp
anywhere
that is um x amount of feet off of a
road
on either national forest or
blm land yeah and um
you yeah you can't start fires
everywhere or really anywhere right now
but you have this there's a sense of
freedom that you don't have to reserve a
campsite
i mean with kovid you can't really
reserve campsites anywhere
that's that the best destinations anyway
they were already reserved and the
capacity was severely
taken down but my plan was
we were going to go up the coast to big
sur
and we were going to uh we're going to
camp there one night and then we're
going to keep going up to monterey and
then we're going to go across to
yosemite
i mean when i made these plans the state
was not burning
but then all of a sudden big sur st big
sur caught on fire
yeah well that's going off of the list
i'm just gonna go to yosemite
and um we can stay outside of the park
there's places you can stay
spots you can stay at i should say but
now
the air quality there is so bad uh the
fires
at least right now aren't in yosemite
but there's so much
smoke coming in that it's not going to
be a good experience
there's still a chance we may go but i'm
i pretty much have decided that we're
not going to yosemite so now i'm like
i was literally just looking at a fi the
fire map
of the western united states and trying
to figure out where we could go that
wasn't on fire
and i was like i think you know utah
it's hard to burn you know because if
you look at uh
i'm just based on the fire maps now i
think i'm going to utah
now zion is very restrictive yeah you
gotta get a shuttle to go in there so i
don't think we're going to zion
but they're part i my understanding
because i may
end up in utah right so my route if one
of my routes takes me
all the way to utah and then down
to through zion and i and i'm just
i would still just be on blm you know
national forest land and stuff
not going into the actual national parks
if you get too far into utah there's
just not a lot to burn
i mean i'm i'm speaking out of turn here
but that's just the impression i get
like it's a bunch of
rock formations well that's why forest
that's why all the fires are
west of the 395 because even here
even on the eastern side of the so i
guess that's the eastern sierras
you just look at a satellite map it's
like it's it's there's just not a lot of
vegetation right now
so i'm trying to find a place that's not
wicked hot
it's not going to be that hot it's not
going to be at elevation i think we're
going to bryce
canyon or we're going around that area
but again we're just gonna we can find
places to
we're doing the same thing you're doing
i'm just doing it in like a really nice
van right so that i'm glamping
and you're you're just i mean your
mind's gonna be it's not really roughing
it i mean this
it's it's not it's not glamping but it's
easier than regular camping yeah yeah
and
the whole i mean the whole idea for me
is the is to be like i don't know
exactly where i'm gonna
park tonight and then roll this you know
roll this tin out
yeah i want to be alone right
and so my philosophy going into this is
i'm driving north kind of kind of feel
it out
and i'm doing as much as i can
to literally like follow my instincts
it's kind of it follow my heart
wherever it is right it's like i'm
physically going somewhere
i don't have specific plans and i'm
going to take it as it comes and i'm
going to
i'm going to try to have an attitude
correct me if i'm wrong of embracing
whatever whatever no presents itself
and that is a very difficult thing for
me to do because i'm thinking about
like i've been looking at this looking
at these maps and like thinking i could
go to this one
right or am i going to be in the mood to
drive that far if i want to go to this
one what if i get there and like it's
closed
because of the fires or it's closed for
some other reason or there's just a
bunch of people there and i can't like
or in many of these places there's a
bunch of naked people there i don't mind
that
but what if i wanted to get naked am i
gonna get naked with a bunch of people
that i don't know
anything's on the table so the whole the
exercise is still legit are you if you
show up at a play
a spring and there's naked people there
what are you gonna do
uh i'm just gonna uh
get in with my bathing suit on probably
if they're naked
yeah i don't i mean just be naked i
haven't thought about it you know what
i'm going to wait and i'm going to
follow my heart in the moment
my heart says let it all hang out it is
going to be hard
it will be hard for me i'll put it this
way to not be thinking about
the okay the report that i would come
back and give to you
i mean the last solo trip it
there were there was meaningful things
that happened but
i do remember constantly thinking about
how it was going to uh
you know what kind of stories i was
going to be able to tell that would like
make make it more valuable but not in
not in
that's not the value you see but i
talked so i talked about this this
aspect i actually
i hesitated even talking about this trip
for this very reason right
uh and i talked about this whole process
with my therapist
because i i said you know i have a
tendency for
for a couple things to happen number one
i can be so focused on
uh not accomplishing something that
that becomes something i'm trying to
accomplish
you know i'm so focused on letting go
that if i feel like i can't let go then
i feel like i
haven't met the expectation of letting
go of expectations
so you really get inside your own head
right but the other thing is
is i think that i have to have something
to bring
back and that can be
this is what happened in my mind and my
heart while i was on this trip
this is the epiphany that i had this is
the
realization that i had at the third day
in the middle of a meditation
while i was tracking the sun you know
or something funny's got to happen so
i've got the story of whether or not i
got naked at the spring so i can come
back on your biscuits and tell it
and so my mission
and again there's really no way to let
go of this seeming like a mission
is to not have a mission and to
literally be like
i don't i'm not trying to get myself
into situation i'm not trying to take a
lot of times we'll do something or take
a risk
like the time that i went to that yoga
class
on my uh solo uh we've taken a couple of
solo
that i went to joshua tree one time but
another solo
trip is when i went to uh the beach and
i took that in the yoga class and i was
the only guy in there and it was a
hilarious story
you know there's a part of me that went
to that yoga class knowing that
something funny might happen that i
could talk about on your biscuits yeah
and
and i like living life like that in
certain ways in some ways because i feel
like it leads me into better experiences
but for this trip i can't even promise
that i'm going to even tell you how it
went
because it may be that i get something
that i feel like is just for me
and to share it would make it would like
ruin it so
it may be that like i'll wait and share
it later
because i i honestly i don't i'm just
trying to be open
i am going to try to make contact with
aliens that is one of the things that is
going to happen well
okay
you told me after that netflix wreck
no i know we we've talked there's been a
number of documentaries well there's
another okay so again
that seems like this seems like a
totally different yeah we'll talk about
we'll talk about this more later but you
and i and here's the thing i don't
believe that any of this is real
but i'm just trying to be a person who
doesn't just conclude
things before being open to them
and the whole steve dr steven greer
thing he's got a couple of documentaries
on netflix
he's the guy that had some access he
worked
area 51 or whatever and he's and he
swears that there's
extraterrestrials and they are in kind
people are in contact with him
and then he has this whole app where
the idea is that through meditation
usually group meditation
you can make contact with these aliens
right
now do i believe that this is what's
actually happening
i would be so surprised if that's what's
actually happening
but if it was what was actually
happening it wouldn't be cool
you know what i mean and so i'm just
again coming from
and a lot of this is sort of continuing
to peel back
the layers of spending my entire
life my you know up until about 10 years
ago or so
really entrenched in an evangelical
worldview
and one of the things that comes along
for me personally with the evangelical
worldview
is just the the belief that that you
have
arrived at the ultimate truth right i
specifically remember
even as a college student thinking man
it's so cool that i believe the correct
thing
it's so cool that i know that
jesus is the only way to have a
connection with the creator of the
universe and that i have a relationship
with him
and that i have arrived at this truth
that is the ultimate truth
like i remember thinking that as a
college student you know and you know 20
years later i'm at this place where it's
just like
the only thing i know is that i don't
know anything
and it's a completely different place to
be but when you have this world view
that it's all about having this you know
systematic theology
all this stuff kind of wrapped up
together and it's kind of impenetrable
right
and you're not really supposed to poke
it and if you do poke it you're supposed
to do it for the sake of just building
it up making it
making it even stronger to me
it's a good exercise for me to be like
now i have absolutely
no reason to believe that i'm going to
have contact with aliens
but what does it feel like to sit down
in the middle of the desert and uh and i
actually bought because they
suggested that you buy this chair that
is one of those
chairs that the anti-gravity chair
basically that you can kind of float you
can kind of lean back
okay a recliner it's it's basically a
recliner for the desert
or the beach an alien recliner and stare
at the sky
does it like it points your butthole in
the right place for a probe right yeah
he opens you straight up to it
okay uh like there's gonna be a moment
where i am just relaxed in a place
where i'm out there it's just me
and nature and i'm gonna be open
to extraterrestrial interaction now
rhett and if that happens
i will talk about it we remember what
what happened when you got scared on
your solo trip and you ran into your
oh i sent and watched super bad i
certainly expect on your laptop that is
going to be a struggle
i certainly expect you're going to get
scared that being scared
and that and the funny thing about that
is that i actually could like hear the
highway
and see cars like a couple of miles away
i'm going to be in some places if i can
get
to the places that i want to go where
like i have a satellite phone
fyi because i'm going to be by myself
and i'm going to be
well outside of any sort of cell service
i've got a satellite foam
that sends uh oh and by the way
you're listed as the second emergency
contact behind my wife so
which may not be great because you're
going to be like on your own trip
but i will have the ability to do an sos
i have the ability to text
and basically text my location and i can
get somebody to come rescue me for a lot
of money
uh if things get real bad
okay but i plan i i i i'm definitely
gonna get scared
i definitely relate to the expectation
thing i mean in general
in my life i'm i'm trying to deal
with you know how
you know how i place expectations on
things and
and how i seek to control things and um
perfect things and um one of the
questions that i'm learning to ask
is what is my desired outcome
because i've start i've and through that
i notice that a lot of the things that i
do and actions that i take to assert
control
that make me feel good actually don't
have
don't move me towards the desired
outcome if i were to state what that is
now that's actually different than i
think you're describing an exercise that
is let go of desire for an outcome
so i'm not going to say that whoa
you're moving the whole table well you
keep hitting the table and it's making
noise and i'm trying to
well that guy what you're doing is not
making noise it made it worse
all right they got it they get that's
good enough that's basically where it
was
but just you know what embrace
the wobbliness of the table this is this
is what we found
here we are all right that's good this
is a good exercise be here now and i
usually don't care about this kind of
thing you usually you would be the one
that you
know i was making a point okay good i
don't remember it
because you shimmy the table that was a
test aggressively it was a test
i think those are i mean they're two
different like knowing what my desired
outcome
is for me and stating that is just a
is an exercise to help me know if i'm
fixating on things for the wrong reason
just for the sake of control
i think it's just a different exercise
what what you're doing
but i'd i do think there's an element of
that for me in this trip as well that
i'm trying to
okay my desired outcome is to
have you know have a quality
experience with christy for us to have a
good time together for us to come back
and have a good time
just period you know we had to cancel
our 20-year anniversary trip
we were going to go to big sur and like
stay in this cabin it was going to be
really cool
we had to cancel all that because of
coved and
um instead of trying to rebook something
like that i'm going with this van
dream test type thing but yeah it could
i could very easily put so much pressure
on
her yeah to
have a good time and to like this thing
and to embrace
my dream and fantasy for us
like living the van life
or or and put so much pressure on myself
to create an experience that would win
her over
versus this may be the only experience
we have in a van
you know it may suck it may be great but
it's gonna we're gonna be together
and it's you know i just want to set it
up for quality and it's not about
going to a certain destination and then
saying okay well
if we go here these are the pictures all
these people take on instagram these are
the things we got to see okay
that means we got to do this trail we
got to hike this trail
well that means we've got to get on this
shuttle that means we've got to park
here that means we gotta
you know all of these things that are
about well my desired outcome
is not to have instagramable moments
or be able to say that i did
when i say i went to bryce canyon and
someone says oh did you do this
so-and-so
it doesn't matter if my answer is yes or
no to them
right it's interesting how i can fall
into that trap so easily
it's like unless i meet someone who
knows more than me about something that
i'm doing if i don't
don't meet their expectations then i've
failed because i haven't
i haven't done a i haven't had a perfect
trip yeah well and there's a
way you didn't you went you didn't see
the so-and-so and there's a fear of
missing out too i mean i remember the
first time
we went to disney world with my wife's
family
right so this is a big trip her parents
i guess at that point we may or may not
have had any kids i can't remember
but my brother and sister-in-law had
at least a kid and then we and we had
uh gaga and papa with us
and they both rest in peace but they
were both alive at the time okay that
makes it easier
and the idea so
what i did when i found out we're going
to disney world
itinerary man uh and and here's the
funny thing is i talk about it like
you know i when somebody you when your
best friend is
as uh efficiency driven as you are
yeah you begin to think that you are
not you begin to think that you're this
like happy-go-lucky guy
until you interact with normal people or
people who are on the opposite end of
the spectrum
and then you realize that i realize that
i am
so much more concerned about planning
and efficiency than
my wife's family and also probably than
the average person right or i'm probably
somewhere in the middle of the spectrum
but for this trip i bought the book
i and i was like okay we've got five
days here
these are the parks we need to visit
this is the we need to literally go
around the park
in this direction we need to get fast
passes for this ride we need to skip
this ride
and i was like if because we want to hit
all the hot spots so i remember
but that wasn't breaking that plan out
for
them and it was almost like okay mister
ruin everyone's fun you know what i'm
saying
they're because they're flying that was
their take on it their philosophy was
let's just
go in let's you know we why do we have
to get up so
early and have breakfast and get there
before people and make sure you do this
can we just go in there now there is a
balance let me just say there's a
balance because if you could take the
complete
opposite no planning no foresight you
might go and be like we didn't do
anything fun all i did was wait in two
lines all day because i didn't think
about this
but the but when you get in my that's
what i'm trying to i'm trying to strike
the balance the balance between being
prepared
and having a plan but having no
expectation that that
plan will be met and not thinking that
success is the plan being accomplished
right these certain expectations so
being prepared
but having no expectations it's like
those those are two
maybe we're saying different i think
we're saying the same maybe we're saying
the same thing because i'm like
if i say my desired outcome is to
enjoy christie's company
and for her to enjoy mine and that that
means i have to stay
in a certain mind frame that's you know
enjoyable
you know i can't fall for my own traps
which make me someone who's not fun to
be around
because i get in my head about oh we
this is
this isn't working and also i'm a
failure oh yeah
yeah definitely yeah so it's if that's
my desired outcome then it's oh it's not
about going on the right trail or
getting to the certain place or
or camping at the place with the most
perfect view
and then if it if it happens you're like
wow bonus
um is that the same is that similar to
what you're saying in terms of like
letting go of expectations
yeah it's the same thing i mean for you
again i i
think this is that whole uh
enneagram one enneagram three presenting
in a very similar way in the way that
they
approach things for you it might be
about
controlling it and doing it perfectly
and for me it might be a slightly
different
twist on that of just like accomplishing
a certain number of things
in its in its uh effect it's kind of the
same thing it's like
i'm going into this trip i'm thinking
that now i don't have an i
because i am not trying to go to
anything other than there's a couple of
like
hot springs that i definitely want to
see so if i didn't see those if i didn't
make it to those or something about that
aspect of it was screwed up that's
that's gonna present itself as a
disappointment but it's not really like
a sightseeing trip
it may be the case that i drive into the
wilderness on day one and then i'm just
like
i'm gonna stay here for six days are you
gonna keep my
truck right here and i'm just gonna stay
here yeah
and cause and be okay with that because
being alone and driving and being along
in one place is a different thing i do
i do expect at least one of the places
to be a place that i would be like okay
because it's not like every morning i'm
gonna wake up
i'm gonna eat some breakfast really
quickly and then i'm gonna fold my tent
up and just get back on the road
yeah i fully expect i'm like well today
i'm just going to stay here
i'm going to sleep in the same way at
what point do you think you're going to
start speaking audibly to yourself
early on early on huh yeah
yeah i wonder i wonder if i would speak
i'm not even gonna there's not gonna be
a time i would do that anyway yeah i
think it would
it would take me a take me a good number
of days before i start speaking out loud
to myself
but then once i did it maybe that would
open up a whole stream of
self-realization well the thing is i'm
trying to figure out what is the best
way to document it again
i often will
journal something and i'll journal it in
a way as if it will be read in the
future yeah because i
because well you know case in point when
we did the the
the deconstruction the lost years yeah i
read from my journal right
and and i i am
narcissistic enough to have this
idea that someone will be interested in
reading my journal right
and the idea that for this thing it's
like okay well what what i'm gonna do
like am i gonna
you haven't decided what you're gonna do
well i've got multiple options i've got
i mean i'm gonna have my computer with
me i'm gonna take my computer for
typing things but i was also there was a
part of me that was like
what if i just take
a pen in a notebook i don't write well
i get some like carpal tunnel situations
when i try to write and i and
i have writer's fatigue with my hand and
much better at typing
but i was like should i just do voice
memos should i do a video don't do a
video because then you'll be tempted to
film it in a way that can be turned into
something and then i'm like well i've
got my drone
and it would be really interesting to
like get like a drone shot of everywhere
i stayed
for my own sake but you know when i'm
doing that i'm going to be thinking
about well one day
not anytime soon but like years from now
i'll be like i went on this trip and
here's all the drone footage you know
maybe next week and so the
that's what i'm struggling with right
now because also i've got my three i've
got lots of tech right so i've got my
360 camera
so i'm like okay i could do a 360 shot
of every campsite and
again i've done that in the past because
it's cool to be able to like put vr on
and like be
there again i think you should do the
360 camera thing that's
that's that's nice to be able to i mean
if you're spending time
at a spot and you're like you're you
should
i mean obviously you're going to journal
i think that's a good idea because then
you can
you know at certain moments of insight
in my past it's like it's it's nice like
if i was listening to certain music
it's nice to put that music back on and
it's it's a it's a way to go back there
you know that so the vr thing is another
way like literally you could go back to
that spot
if you're listening to music and like
you're on vr in the spot again like
it could it could really bring magically
bring you back to a spot where
that could be special i think so you
know like a happy place
or maybe it's a sad place it's a
poignant place
i so i think that's a cool idea uh
yeah the video thing is um i'm not gonna
be difficult but like pictures i mean
again we
we've talked about this on a whole
episode where you got it you got to take
some pictures
do it do it for you yeah and that and
again that's the thing it's like
how can i be in the and this is it's
really this is just a microcosm of what
i want my life to be and this is this is
a whole nother can of worms but right
how can i be in the world
in a way that isn't about
look at me and look at what i can do
right
and isn't and that's a very difficult
thing for someone who makes a living
saying look at what i can do or saying
if you don't look at what i can do and
enjoy it
then i don't make a living i don't have
a company the hair thing
is is a is an
easy place to point for that quandary
right because
as we discussed you you know you have
your reasons for doing it
yet you knew at the time eve
and you you definitely seen it playing
out that like
people have to comment on how big your
hair is like
you know how big your beard is that type
so you knew that was
it was gonna present some sort of um
tension
right and i think that there's so much
i'm curious on an update there update on
my hair
well i mean it was you did it as a form
of embodiment it's related to all of
these things it's like
it's a physical representation of
something that is going
on within you and your mindset but you
knew that like
you you would you have to deal with
people's reaction to it response to it
discussion of it well i think i'm
i think i'm kind of past the point of
i'm not i'm not past
i'm not past it in other words yeah i'm
fully aware of that dynamic and that
struggle
of it being like oh well people are
saying they really like my hair
how do i not gravitate towards that type
of commentary about it
and and uh actually get something from
it like it's rewarding to have people
talk about how they like your hair right
for me it's more about
this idea that when i
look at pictures before i grew my hair
out
it feels less like me now
i'm not saying i'm not going to go back
to a short hair or whatever i'm not
damn i'm going to have long hair forever
but i do think that part of the exercise
was you have this i think that life is
about
to use a meme becoming your final form
right
like you know you
i think this is what every religion
teaches ultimately is like
you are trying to continue
to move closer to something if it's an
eastern philosophy it might
be enlightenment christianity is like
you're trying to become more and more
christ-like
we're kind of talking about very similar
things of
trying like see having some sort of
trajectory
in trajectory in your your life right
and for me this idea of kind of
getting more in touch with myself not
just being in my head all the time
following my heart i have begun to sort
of
feel a cohesiveness
with that when it comes to having a big
beard
and big hair right so
that aspect of it is like not mission
accomplished but
sensing that yes that there is something
to that
like i feel i let that i
look more i i think i look more like i
feel about the world
now um so that's the update
is that that has happened to some degree
i don't know i don't know where it's
going to go from here
um so next week
next time we record it will be after the
trip because we're about to go on these
trips
who knows if we'll even decide to talk
about it at all
seems like i've got a lot more leeway to
talk about it than you do
but maybe not well you know that was the
last thing i was going to say was it's
not a desired outcome of mine i think i
have to get to a place
where i can't expect
the environment and the way that the
world works
to change in order for me to be okay
right i i can't expect
people to stop talking about a change
that i make physically
right that's going to continue to happen
whether i'm
on camera on people's computers or not
right
but i could but i do believe i could get
to a place where it
really doesn't matter and it's not about
accolades or getting some sort of
feedback outside of myself right
it's it's this idea that what i need
is not some external thing it's not some
validation it's not my environment being
what it should be i shouldn't have to
curate a solo trip in order to get to
the place that i want to get to
emotionally spiritually right right now
those it may be helpful to do that
but ultimately what would when we all
like to get to a place where
regardless of the circumstances you have
this equanimity that you can
access right and
so i think that
that's the challenge for me is like go
and like don't overthink it like do you
want a drone you want to
get break the drone out yeah just break
the drone out do it for yourself
if you don't if you don't if you if you
don't do anything
so that you can talk about it or share
it
and then you come back and you want to
talk about it or share it
secondarily go for it right find out
what replaced
getting to a place where you can just be
motivated by i just i'm just cause the
only person that's gonna miss
out is you right or me if that's
our mentality if i mean like
it christy may miss out of some of me
and i may miss out on some of myself and
you might miss out on
some of yourself if you're if you're
doing things for
the effect or the story right so so
maybe you can tell me about it
because i'm going to want to know but
don't think about me
don't think about these people listening
while you're out there
i don't think about you at all and let's
not get
let's not get close to any fires i'm
committed to that
that we that's one thing we didn't talk
about i'm not getting close to any fires
it's not necessarily just staying away
from the fires that are already
happening
you go into the wrong place in the
forest and a fire starts and there's one
way out
that could be a whole different kind of
story i mean
either one of us are going to forests i
think it is
not going to forest i'm not go well i
mean there's going to be some foresty
areas that i'm going to be going in well
be careful but i have thought about this
and here's my here here is my here's my
take on this
you tell me if you think this is a good
plan if i
find myself in a situation where like i
wake up in the middle and i'm like oh
crap there's a fire coming towards me
and there's just one dirt road that came
in here
and i can look down this mountain and
see that the fire is coming towards me
and i got no way out okay
my theory is
you just drive right through it gosh i
didn't want you to say
that at the end of this podcast wow
everything i just said
was for the effect of anyone listening
wouldn't be worried about it
but oh my god i can't wait until the
next ear biscuit to see if they
live but fire burns in a line
here here i ca can i say this i'm saying
this as no not i'm not an expert on this
let me say that
just to put you at ease listener
if something would have happened to
either one of us you would have heard
about it before
this episode even came out this one this
conversation we're having right now so
we'll cut this out if i if i
die in a fire what you're saying yeah
okay so but if i lift through it this
would be pretty awesome if you're
listening to this you know that this
didn't happen okay
so now you can cut the full all you want
about driving through a fire
because it's like you're not even
supposed to drive through a like a
flooded street
hold on but this seems worse no okay if
i feel like there's a way that i can
get to i wouldn't by the way i wouldn't
camp anywhere that there's only one way
out well that's the only kind of places
i'm gonna be man i mean like if the road
kept going and there was a second way
down the mountain or whatever
that's my that's my advice all i'm
saying is that fire burns in a line so
there's this fire burning the perimeter
of the fire
and on the inside of the perimeter of
the fire it's not like the whole thing's
of blaze it's black it's just burned it
went through
and i mean the fire burning zone
is probably no more than 100 yards
i i'm not gonna respond if you get fast
enough
sure both your tires will probably i'm
not going to be there you may almost
cook
but i'm saying if there's no other way
out i'm driving right through the fire
i think you should do something and i
will film that do some more research
okay if that's what you're thinking
you're going to do do some more
research before i'm sure it does do you
think you're going to go on some site
and it says
if you find yourself in the situation
drive into the fire
no one in any survival book is going to
is going to
say or suggest you could no i'm saying
that
they they would never suggest that but
i'm saying that there's got to be
circumstances where that is the thing
that you should do
read about it no i don't take my advice
and you do your own research
he is not giving it i'm not giving
advice this is just my personal
philosophy
uh that i'm conjecturing about see i
knew there was an impending doom
feeling that i had for a reason i have a
wreck
wreck baby wreck because you're weak as
as we do with mini rex we uh we tend to
recommend things like movies that have
been out for a while because we just
slowly get to things
um so no one's talking about this
anymore but that's why you should go
watch it
that andy sandberg movie palm springs i
mean i heard people saying you know what
that's
a it's a good movie it's a really good
movie
it's just a it's just a you know it's
it's obviously a comedy um
but it is a you probably
you probably already know this because
this is how all the trailers
and everything that's been it's been
about it's basically an update on the
groundhog day idea
and it is
so well done and it's like it's like
they sat down and thought
oh man let's revisit this concept of of
somebody being stuck in a time loop
but really just think about it in a way
that any conversations that people have
had over the past 30 years about
groundhog day let's put let's put some
of those things into a movie
and you'll you'll understand when you
when you watch it but also
it really asks some interesting
questions like not real directly they're
pretty subtle
the idea of the meaning of life and how
you find purpose
and what uh where that comes comes from
and
i just really enjoyed it huh palm
springs how long
is it it's not too long it's an hour and
a half okay
again all the all the good movies are an
hour and a half now
maybe even 85 minutes you got to get
them you don't have to watch the crap
you can't tell the story in 90 minutes
in 2020 then
you probably shouldn't make the movie i
mean that's my new philosophy
unless you're zack snyder yeah okay
was he making three three hour movies i
think the snyder cut was like
it's like four hours or something they
were the way that they're releasing it
okay you know what i might check that
out palm springs
andy sandberg it's i have a problem
watching andy sandberg because like
i have this weird thing where it's like
he was you know he's in lonely island
we used to have all these comparisons i
like you guys are like lonely island but
not as funny he'll be like
you're right yeah i mean just embrace it
i know and then it's like
it makes me not like to
enjoy him that's my own problem i will
enjoy it he's really good in it
he's definitely better than we would be
yeah
okay i'll check it out hashtag gear
biscuits wish us luck
even though again i'm not going to do
that i'm not going to drive
we're already back and we're still alive
and uh
maybe we'll talk about it next episode
maybe we'll talk about
why we're not going to talk about it but
we'll you'll get enough we'll talk about
something
hashtag ear biscuits to watch more ear
biscuits click on the playlist on the
right
to watch the previous episode of your
biscuits click on the playlist to the
left and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best